one of the oddest things about economic
life is that the prices for things
keeps rising incomes and prices in the
past
were amazingly different from what they
are today in pride and prejudice
mr darcy is supposed to have been one of
the richest people in britain
it's 1813 and his income is 10 000
pounds a year
today that's less than half of what a
primary school teacher straight out of
college would earn
in sense and sensibility there's an
argument about whether an income of 20
pounds a week
is enough to make you well off and the
answer is yes
it's there in living memory too a cinema
ticket was 30p in 1970
today it's 13 pounds so why does
inflation happen
and should we worry if it does
governments track inflation obsessively
and try to keep it low there's a vast
amount of data collected all the time
to ensure that governments can say with
amazing precision
how the inflation rate is going is it on
track for 2.3 percent per annum
or might the increase of 0.38 in
february be a cause for alarm
this is in big historical terms a
relatively new concern
in the 17th century the spanish empire
essentially collapsed from inflation
without even realizing it was occurring
so over time
societies have become obsessed with
measuring inflation
and very focused on managing it so why
is there inflation
what makes it happen there are basically
three reasons
the first is what economists call cost
push
inflation this is where the cost of
businesses rise
and are then passed on to customers
there can be a lot of reasons for these
rises
firstly raw materials especially oil
might get more expensive
for a very nice reason because a lot of
countries are developing and doing well
secondly workers might be asking for
more money and succeeding either because
they've organized themselves well
politically
or because schools and colleges haven't
been training enough workers in the
skills that companies need
thirdly land rents might be increasing
because not enough factories and offices
have been built
which tends to come down to political
failures around building permits
the result of all this is that
businesses then push their extra costs
onto the consumer
by raising prices they don't want to
it's a scary move
but they have no choice they'd go out of
business otherwise
the second kind of inflation is called
demand inflation
this is when there are increases in the
number of people who want something
whose supply can't keep up
the most common cause of demand
inflation is an otherwise rather nice
thing
that people are getting richer and have
more money to spend
that's why government can cause
inflation by lowering taxes
everyone loves tax breaks because they
raise disposable income
but in the longer term raising demand
can also cause price rises
thereby negating some of the initial
boost of the tax break
similarly a fall in interest rates may
cause short-term pleasure and long-term
inflationary pressure
if interest rates on loans or mortgages
fall we might be tempted to take out a
loan to buy the new car we've always
wanted
but the car company sensing solid demand
will soon enough jack up the price
if banks and governments inject more
cash and credit into the economy
people have more money to spend but if
they're all chasing the same number of
goods as before
it just means they can all offer more
for the same
this is what happened around housing in
the uk particularly in london
there are broadly the same number of
houses there were 25 years ago
but they all cost an absurd amount more
the third classic cause of inflation is
governments printing money
there's a deep logic behind this idea
which can at first sound almost criminal
governments often want to stimulate the
economy to create more jobs
so they print more money this can be
done literally by increasing the number
of notes in circulation
or they can do it by increasing
government debt or by letting banks make
bigger loans on the same security
in all these cases the amount of money
in circulation increases
but there's a big problem because after
a while it means the worth of every note
starts to fall because more notes are
chasing the same number of things to buy
there's more money about but it doesn't
buy you more
it just pushes up prices however there
is a possibility here
spotted by the economist and philosopher
john maynard keynes
it takes time for the value of money to
fall
so for a little while there can be more
cash around
and prices haven't yet risen this is a
window of opportunity that economies can
with a lot of luck
sees at such goldilocks moments people
can actually
increase their consumption firms can
afford to hire more workers and buy new
machinery
and once they've done that production
will increase there will be more stuff
to buy
before inflation is eaten up again so
there's a real expansion
a bit of inflation can grow the economy
that's a big but contested idea the
argument is that it doesn't matter if
prices are going up 10
every year if wages are going up 15
so deliberate government-led inflation
can be a mechanism for growing the
economy
but it's a very risky move which is
often backfired
and been attacked by the great enemies
of the keynesian economists
people we now know as the monetarists
who believe that anything which
increases inflation
is always going to be an issue and must
be avoided at all costs
whatever the short term so why is
inflation such a problem the real
problem is that not everything inflates
at exactly the same rate
if everything went up by a hundred
percent a year and so did everyone's
income
and it was all totally steady and
predictable it would be weird but it
wouldn't actually do any harm
the harm comes from the fact that not
everything changes at the same
rate in 1941 in hungary inflation
reached 150 000 percent
each day a jelly bean that cost 10p on
monday morning
would therefore cost the equivalent of
150 pounds on tuesday morning and 225
000 pounds on wednesday morning that's
incredibly complicated
but it's a problem only because other
things would not be increasing
as fast if you kept your life savings
under the mattress
you'd be wiped out in a day or two the
money that could have brought you a
house on monday
would get you a jelly bean on wednesday
this is the ultra extreme case
but it illustrates a basic point
inflation is bad
for savings there's no point in putting
money aside
and that's a pity because saving money
the attitude of saving up for things
before you buy them
is an admirable characteristic keeping
inflation low
rewards prudence it helps long-term
planning
because you can know what your money
will be worth in the future
and this rewards taking care around
costs
ultimately what inflation reflects is
the instability of the world
and of life itself prices rise because
we can't yet keep the complex system
known as the economy under control
there's always something going wrong or
growing or falling or failing somewhere
ideally we'd keep inflation under
control with a more or less fixed amount
of money
chasing a more or less stable amount of
goods but in reality
low inflation is extremely difficult to
achieve because
so many factors can derail it cost of
materials
cost of labor productivity taxes falling
or rising exchange rates again falling
or rising
a growing domestic economy a neighboring
economy that's growing
falling interest rates the buying of
government bonds or the printing of
money
in the end we may have to accept that
inflation is a bit like the weather or
our own moods
something that's inherently rather
unstable something whose ups and downs
we must endure
even as we try to mitigate the extremes
learning to live with inflation
belongs to wisdom
you